Georg City wird von einer
Flüchtlingswelle getroffen wieder gibt
es Zeltstädte in New York mehr als
20.000 Einwanderer sind in den letzten
Wochen in den Big Apple gekommen viele
kamen mit Bussen aus grenzbundesstaaten
wie Texas und Arizona Bild ist vor Ort
und unser Kollege Herbert Bauer Nebel
der berichtet aus New York
New York im Ausnahmezustand
bürgermeister Eric Adams hat den
Notstand ausgerufen Grund sind
zigtausende Flüchtlinge die gerade nach
New York kommen die Stadt im krisenmodus
zum ersten Mal seit Beginn der Pandemie
werden wieder Zeltstädte in New York
City errichtet BILD-Reporter Herbert
Bauer Nebel ist vor Ort hier in dieser
Zeltstadt möchte man eine Art
Auffanglager errichten man möchte hier
Migranten unterbringen für eine Weile
bis man eben weiß wo sie hingehen können
ob sie Jobs bekommen wie Sie hier
einfach ein Leben beginnen können in New
York City die Stadt ist in einer
schweren Krise mehr als
1000 Migranten sind hier in den letzten
Wochen angekommen
republikanische Gouverneure der
Südstaaten wie Texas oder Arizona leiten
sie nach New York weiter um den Druck
auf die liberale Stadt zu erhöhen die
Notunterkünfte der Stadt sind voll die
Stadtverwaltung suchten nun verzweifelt
nach Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten
Migranten werden in Hotels untergebracht
und ihren hungrig und frierend durch die
Vororte im Stadtteil Staten Island
spricht Bild mit Sebastian bon Giovanni
er hat erst vor kurzem seine Pizzeria
hier eröffnet und versorgt Flüchtlinge
jetzt mit Essen
vor zehn Tagen tauchen plötzlich Leute
hier auf sie sahen sehr hungrig aus wir
wussten nicht wo sie herkam aber wir
gaben ihn zu essen
mehr Leute dann verstanden wir was da
gerade passiert bekommt die
Millionenmetropole den Ansturm in den
Griff und wie viele Migranten schicken
die Südstaaten noch nach New York City
und jetzt schauen wir live zu Herbert
Bauer Nebel Herbert also beschreib uns
noch mal die aktuelle Situation in New
York wie schlimm es ist tatsächlich
es ist eine durchaus schwierige
Situation denn die Zahl der Migranten
ist in den letzten Wochen relativ
dramatisch gestiegen allein am
Wochenende kamen hier 2000 Menschen an
in Mitter Manhattan und dann natürlich
herrscht hier ein wenig Chaos denn man
weiß oft nicht wo diese Menschen diese
Migranten hin sollen denn die
Obdachlosenunterkünfte sind alle voll
das sind mehr als 61.000 Menschen
bereits dort da gibt es keinen Platz
mehr deshalb versucht man diese Menschen
unterzubringen wo immer es nur geht um
das Ganze reicht jetzt von einem
Luxushotel in mittern Manhattan eben bis
zu Hotels of statten Island und das ist
ein ganz ein ruhiger vor Ort eigentlich
von New York und dort irren diese
Migranten eigentlich relativ ziellos
herum viele haben keine warme Kleidung
einige sind einfach nur hungrig und die
gehen dann vom Tür zu Tür und Klopfen an
bei Menschen und bitten um Essen und um
Entscheidung das ist schon eine relativ
ungewöhnliche Situation besonders für
die Menschen die in diesen Vororten
Leben es ist hier klar zu sehen dass es
keine klare Politik hier gibt kein gute
Logistik für diese Migranten und der
Druck in New York steigt hier fast
täglich Herbert was man hier nicht so
ganz verstehen kann ist dass die
Südstaaten einfach Ihre Flüchtlinge nach
New York weiterleiten können wie kann
das sein
spielt natürlich einerseits viel Politik
mit den republikanischen Gouverneure wie
eben in Texas wollen die liberale
Metropolen teilhaben lassen am Druck der
entstanden ist durch diese wirklich
historische Einwanderungswelle man muss
man muss dazu sagen dass in den letzten
zwölf Monaten 2,1 Millionen illegale
Grenzübertritte gezählt worden das ist
ein gewaltiger Druck der hier besonders
an den
grenzbundesstaaten wie eben Texas und
Arizona lastet um diese republikanischen
Gouverneure sagen ganz klar wir schicken
die jetzt diese Migranten jetzt in
liberale Städte alles von Chicago New
York bis Boston um eben zu zeigen dass
diese Migrationswelle an enormes Problem
schafft und natürlich andererseits
kommen auch viele Migranten selbst nach
New York weil sie hier Verwandte haben
und man muss auch dazu sagen auch
demokratische Bürgermeister wie etwa in
Klassen schicken Migranten nach New York
Herbert wie sehr spielt das den
Republikanern in die Hände wie sehr
spielt das zum Beispiel auch einem
Donald Trump in die Hände das war ja
immer sein großes Thema die Mauer the
wall
die Migrationswelle ist eines der
Top-Themen bei den kommenden
Kongresswahlen den mitturm Wahlen hier
können die Republikaner Punkten es ist
mittlerweile auch vielen Demokraten
bereits klar dass es mit dieser diesen
Ausmaß dieser Einwanderungswelle einfach
nicht weitergehen kann dass hier
man versuchen muss einfach mehr Fokus zu
legen auf den auf die Sicherung dieser
Grenze natürlich klar ist die Demokraten
können hier schwer jetzt genau die
Argumente verwenden die Donald Trump
gesagt hat der immer gesagt hat ist
Sicherung einer Grenze eines Landes ist
das wichtigste und das ist ein Dilemma
für die Demokraten aber man sieht hier
bereits auch bei den Liberalen eine
kleine Kehrtwende hin zu mehr Kontrolle
an der Grenze
Herbert Bauer Nebel vielen Dank nach New
York
[Musik]